[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Dunja Hayali
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend die Demokratie in
Israel ist stark und lebendig wir werden
keinen Zentimeter davon abweichen das
hatte Ministerpräsident netanjau vor
wenigen Monaten bei seinem Besuch hier
in Deutschland gesagt getan hat er im
Grunde das Gegenteil er ist abgewichen
und das nicht nur um Zentimeter wie
anders soll man das sonst deuten was die
knistert heute beschlossen hat nämlich
ein Gesetz dass die Gewaltenteilung in
Israel teilweise aufhebt ein Gesetz dass
das Oberste Gericht zu einer Art lame
duck umfunktioniert und viele sehen die
liberale Demokratie nun in Gefahr ohne
das Gesetz wäre allerdings die Zukunft
als Ministerpräsident in Gefahr Stefanie
Garage von Anfang an protestierten
Michelmann und ihr Mann mit Monat und
Monate heute vor der Knesset wo sie die
Zufahrt zum israelischen Parlament
blockierten aus Angst dass ihre
Demokratie war
wissen sie meine Familie Flo einst aus
Europa sie überlebten den Holocaust sie
sind die hergekommen um etwas Besseres
für die jüdischen Menschen aufzubauen
und nun steuert alles hier in eine
schlechte Richtung
ihr Protest änderte nichts am Nachmittag
ging es in der Knesset sehr schnell mit
ihrer Mehrheit beschloss die
rechtsreligiöse Koalition von Benjamin
netanjau die angemessenheitsklausel
abzuschaffen ohne nur 1 cm zu weichen
Freude und selfies und ein zufriedener
Regierungschef heute haben wir einen
notwendigen demokratischen Schritt
durchgeführt erzählt darauf ein gewisses
Gleichgewicht zwischen den Gewalten
wieder herzustellen wir haben den
Änderungsantrag aus Gründen der
Angemessenheit verabschiedet damit die
gewählte Regierung die Politik im
Einklang mit der Entscheidung der
Mehrheit der Bürger des Landes leiten
kann
nicht nur für die Opposition eine
Aushebelung der Gewaltenteilung
geschlossen verließen sie die knessel
vor der letzten Lesung Schande riefen
sie Schande
[Applaus]
inzwischen liegt beim Obersten Gericht
eine Klage gegen die Abschaffung des
Gesetzes vor der Oppositionsführer
spricht von einem schwarzen Tag für die
Demokratie
heute ist ein trauriger Tag ein Tag an
dem der Tempel zerstört wurde die
extreme Regierung feiert den Tag an dem
sie alles was uns verbunden hat in den
Mülleimer der Geschichte geworfen hat
der erste Teil der sogenannten
Justizreform sieht vor den Gerichten die
Möglichkeit zu nehmen Entscheidungen der
Regierung zu kippen wenn diese nicht
angemessen erscheinen das israelische
oberste Gericht ist leider die einzige
Kraft neben der Regierung
wir haben keine starken lokalen
Regierungen keine Landesregierung das
Gericht ist das einzige Organ das als
Jack and balance genutzt wird daher ist
dies heute ein Kuh ein Streich gegen die
israelische Demokratie
am Abend gehen die Proteste weiter
erreichen eine neue Qualität an härter
morgen wollen die Beschäftigten des
Gesundheitssystems streiken für 24
Stunden auch wenn die Regierung sie
nicht hören will die Demonstranten
werden wohl weitermachen
Wissenschaft Wirtschaft intellektuelle
sogar das Militär sind empört manche
befürchten gar einen Zerfall der Armee
denn etliche Mitglieder der Armee hatten
im Vorfeld angekündigt sollte das Gesetz
kommen kommen sie nicht mehr zum Dienst
lassen uns das ganze einordnen von
Stefanie gagosch schönen guten Abend ja
was bedeutet das jetzt alles für Israel
und zuallererst mal eine gespaltene
Gesellschaft ein Beschädigung der
Demokratie und einem bröckeln dazu
Zusammenhalt bei der Armee und das ist
die andere historische Komponente so was
gab es vorher noch nie in Israel das
Teile des Militärs sagen wir kommen
nicht mehr zum Dienst wenn dieses Gesetz
durchgeht das sind vor allen Dingen
Reservisten die freiwillig
Dienst machen aber die werden dringend
gebraucht und diese Einheit bröckelt nun
das haben wir gehört ähm und viele
Israelis haben große Angst dass das Land
im Chaos versinkt es gibt eine Umfrage
eines Kanals danach Glauben 67% der
Israelis dass ein bürgerkriegt das ist
ein bisschen hochgegriffen aber
insgesamt sieht es nicht gut aus an
diesem Tag für Israel
soweit die Einschätzungen von Stefanie
gagasch live aus tellerie die das heute
alles vor Ort beobachtet hat vielen Dank
und damit zurück nach Deutschland war es
ein Testballon der allerdings sehr
schnell in der Luft zerrissen wurde oder
war es eine tonübung politischer Natur
Rolle vorwärts Rolle rückwärts
jedenfalls war die Verwirrung groß nach
der Aussage von Friedrich Merz zur
möglichen Zusammenarbeit seiner Partei
mit der AFD in Zitat
Kommunalparlamenten noch größer war im
Grunde nur der Ärger und zwar aus den
eigenen Reihen das was Friedrich Merz da
im ZDF sommerinterview gestern
losgetreten hat hat sich in kürzester
Zeit zu einer Lawine entwickelt die auch
der neue Generalsekretär nachts mit
einem Tweet auf Twitter nicht mehr
stoppen konnte da war die Brandmauer
schon durchlöchert gilt nun der Satz
keine direkte oder indirekte
Zusammenarbeit mit der AFD laut März ja
stellte er dann heute auf Twitter klar
ob das aber auch allen anderen klar ist
Frank Buchwald
sommergespräch der hessischen CDU im
Wiesbadener Schloss Biebrich geht es um
Bildungspolitik und Kritik an der Ampel
im Oktober sind Landtagswahlen und
Debatten um das Verhältnis zur AFD kann
Ministerpräsident rein im Moment so gar
nicht gebrauchen mit Leuten wie mit
Herrn höcke werden wir niemals etwas zu
tun haben zu den gibt es nicht nur eine
Brandmauer sondern zu diesen Menschen
gibt es wirklich einen Graben der
unüberwindbar ist also AFD ist für uns
ein absolutes No-Go klare Worte denn
CDU-Chef Merz hatte gestern im ZDF
sommerinterview einen Satz gesagt der
wie eine Kursänderung Klang im
Verhältnis der Union zur AFD es ist
jetzt in Thüringen ein Landrat gewählt
worden und natürlich ist das eine
demokratische Wahl es ist in
Sachsen-Anhalt ein in einer kleinen
Gemeinde einen Bürgermeister gewählt
worden in der AFD gehört natürlich ist
das eine demokratische Wahl das haben
wir doch zu akzeptieren und natürlich
muss in den Kommunalparlamenten dann
auch nach Wegen gesucht werden wie man
gemeinsam die Stadt das Land den
Landkreis gestaltet
Parteifreunde reagieren entsetzt der
CDU-Chef sieht sich tags drauf zu einer
Klarstellung genötigt März schreibt oft
Twitter es werde auch auf kommunaler
Ebene keine Zusammenarbeit der CDU mit
der AFD geben da aber lodert bereits die
Empörung selbst im eigenen Landesverband
mich ärgert ein bisschen gebe ich zu
dass wir bei der Frage im Grunde die AFD
ja immer noch interessanter machen mit
jeder dieser Debatten interessanter
machen wir müssen viel mehr darüber
nachdenken was können wir als Politiker
tun damit die AFD in ihren Zuwächsen bei
den WählerInnen Wählern verliert das ist
doch das Hauptproblem endlich die
Landesverbände im Osten Thüringen etwa
es braucht Konzentration auf die Themen
der normalen Bürger und eine
Auseinandersetzung mit dem linken
Politik und Gesellschaftsbild der Ampel
heißt es in einer Erklärung der
Landtagsfraktion Debatten um die AFD
bringen Deutschland nicht aus der Krise
auch die bayerische Schwester gibt sich
kompromisslos
wir sind ganz klar gegen jede Form der
Kooperation mit der AFD egal ob auf
europäisch auf Bundes auf Landes- oder
darf kommunaler Ebene ein nein heißt ein
Nein
Beifall bekommt März nur von der AFD
Parteichef krupala freut sich auf
Twitter nun vielen erste Steine aus der
schwarz-grünen Brandmauer in Ländern und
Bund werden wie die Mauer gemeinsam
niederreißen genau dies aber Mehrheiten
mit der AFD befürchtet die Linke und
spd-generalsekretär Kühnert spricht von
Tabubruch genau hier stößt Friedrich
Merz rein und sagt jetzt dass seine CDU
vor Ort eben doch mit der AFD nach
Mehrheiten offenkundig suchen kann und
das ist der Tabubruch der Vorsitzende
der CDU öffnet den Feinden der
Demokratie die Tür in diesem Land ich
halte das für völlig inakzeptabel viele
in Berlin rätseln ob März Vorstoß im
Sommer Interview nur unvorsichtig war
oder doch ein taktischer Schachzug
ausgelöst aber hat er ein politisches
Sommer Gewitter und neue Zweifel
eine Klarstellung und deutliche
Abgrenzung wurde von vielen aus den
eigenen Reihen gefordert die wurde dann
ja auch wir haben es gerade gesehen und
gehört von Friedrich Merz dann auch auf
Twitter geliefert aber hat der
CDU-Vorsitzende da nicht doch einen
Punkt angesprochen den es öffentlich und
ehrlich zu diskutieren gilt und
vielleicht hilft da der Blick auf die
kommunale Realität und hinter die
sogenannte Brandmauer Christian von
Rechenberg
Kooperation ein Miteinander im
Einzelfall darf es nicht geben soll es
nicht geben Brandmauern sind hochgezogen
gegen die AFD und doch schon überwunden
in Bautzen etwa im vergangenen Jahr
Landrat udovicas verhilft da im Kreistag
einem afd-antrag zur Mehrheit hat fast
die ganze CDU-Fraktion hinter sich
insofern kann ich das begrüßen dass dort
zumindest auf kommunaler eben auch bei
der CDU Politiker sind die im Sinne
ihres Kreises handeln und sich nicht der
Partei Doktrinen aus Berlin unterordnen
im Sinne des Kreises soll es für
bestimmte Asylbewerber weniger Leistung
geben eine Maßnahme laut Flüchtlingsrat
mit eher populistischem Wert notabene in
einem Landkreis in dem wenige Wochen
zuvor eine geplante
Flüchtlingsunterkunft angezündet wurde
doch der Antrag sei so der Landrat
inhaltlich anstandslos also zur
unterstützen in der Landeshauptstadt
hätte man lieber einen eigenen Antrag
der CDU gesehen und Friedrich Merz für
der Live Fälle eigentlich
parteiausschlüsse
anders in Thüringen da debattiert die
SPD Anfang diesen Jahres ob es gegen
zwei Mitglieder ein Parteiverfahren
geben soll weil sie mit der AFD
gemeinsame Sache machten im Stadtrat von
Hildburghausen dieser war das
amtierenden Bürgermeisters überdrüssig
die Bürger sollten ihn abwählen können
den Antrag dazu unterstützt sie die
Mehrheit im Stadtrat neben CDU und SPD
auch die AFD zusammen abgestimmt wird
oft aber der Fall ging zu weit
je politischer eine Entscheidung wird je
größer die Tragweite und eine Abwahl
eines demokratisch gewählten Bürgers
Bürgermeisters ist eine riesige
Tragweite dort wird es immer relevanter
ob man jetzt sage ich mal da gemeinsam
mit der AFD agiert oder sie wählt wie in
Rago und Jeßnitz Hannes Lot ist hier
seit wenigen Wochen der erste
hauptamtliche Bürgermeister der AFD in
Deutschland im August nimmt er die
Arbeit auf
AFD polarlich sind vielleicht aber
ansonsten versuche ich recht
ausgesprochen zu sein und auf alle
Seiten zuzugehen zuzuhören zwei seiner
parteilosen gegen Kandidaten wie der
Ängste Verfolger Nils Naumann kündigten
schon an dass sie jede vernünftige
Politik des afd-bürgermeisters
unterstützen und Stadträte könnten sie
gar nicht anders und die Wähler würden
es womöglich gar nicht verstehen
ich persönlich gucke auf die Menschen
und nicht auf die Partei die dahinter
steht Brandmauer vs Pragmatismus
kommunal scheint an der AFD kein
Vorbeikommen einen miteinander erfordert
Fingerspitzengefühl Ostdeutschland
deswegen meiden ein Ministerpräsident
der besorgt ist aber nicht ohne Hoffnung
gab darauf bereits die Antwort
tja und hat er sie noch alle werden sich
vielleicht viele aus der CDU gestern
dann doch gefragt haben als Friedrich
Merz Stadt glasklare Ansage eher für
glasklare Verunsicherung gesorgt hat
lassen wir uns das ganze einordnen von
unserer Hauptstadt Korrespondentin
schakota labana die schönen guten Abend
nach Berlin
guten Abend ja die afd-chefin Alice
Weidel hat heute gesagt die CDU solle
das unsinnige Kontaktverbot aufheben und
das ist doch wir haben es ja gerade im
Grunde gesehen de facto schon passiert
nicht nur bei der CDU es gibt doch
bereits gemeinsames Abstimmungsverhalten
war März da dann vielleicht einfach mal
ganz kurz ehrlich und pragmatisch das
könnte man vielleicht so sagen wenn
nicht Friedrich Merz selbst und seine
Unterstützer heute noch mal sehr darum
bemüht gewesen wären zu betonen dass
trotzdem trotz seiner Aussagen maximale
Distanz zur AFD zu halten sei und das
macht die ganze Sache natürlich relativ
schwer zu beurteilen also was genau ist
jetzt da gemeint auf kommunaler Ebene
tatsächlich ist ja die Frage wie man
umgehen sollte mit der AFD da wo sie
besonders erfolgreich ist und wie man
sich verhält ähm ob man mit ihr
zusammenarbeiten kann und soll als CDU
eine der zentralen Fragen die Friedrich
Merz beantworten muss als
Parteivorsitzende und wo er seine Partei
auch mitnehmen muss das Problem ist nur
er könnte das ja machen einen solchen
Diskussionsvorschlag kann er als
Parteivorsitzender immer machen das
würde ihm auch niemand ankreiden aber
dann müsste er ihn auch als Vorschlag
als vorsichtigen Vorschlag formulieren
und eben die Gremien mitnehmen die
Partei mitnehmen dass als Prozess
gestalten das hat er hier nicht getan
und deswegen dürfte die Kritik auch so
laut sein und viele aus den insbesondere
aus Verbänden warten da vielleicht auch
auf eine Antwort weil sie ja auch
tagtäglich quasi mit der AFD im
politischen Geschäft zu tun haben die
Kritik aus den eigenen Reihen war wir
haben es gerade auch noch mal gehört
extrem und die kamen dann ja nicht mal
von den üblichen Verdächtigen wie Daniel
Günther oder Hendrik wüst und sie kamen
dann auch noch öffentlich was sagt das
eigentlich über Friedrich Merz aus oder
über auch über den Zustand der CDU
es sagt glaube ich relativ viel über den
Zustand der CDU aus nämlich vor allem
dass die im Partei immer noch mit der
Identitätsfrage beschäftigt ist mit der
sie sich schon seit 2018 spätestens
rumschlägt nämlich der entscheidenden
Frage wo von der Mitte aus betrachtet
möchte sie denn eigentlich
zusätzliche Stimmen herholen soll das
links von der Mitte sein oder eher
rechts von der Mitte und wie weit ist
man dann bereit dazu gehen diese Frage
spaltet die Partei und sollte eigentlich
unter dem Parteivorsitzenden in
Friedrich Merz geklärt werden sie ist
aber eben noch nicht geklärt und
Friedrich Merz hat es auch nicht
geschafft aus eigener Kraft der Partei
ein klares konservatives Profil zu geben
was viele gehofft hatten die CDU hat
sich vorgenommen ein paar
programmparteialltag im kommenden Jahr
zu machen auf dem solche Fragen dann
geklärt werden könnten allerdings zeigt
sich jetzt dass die Zeit vielleicht mehr
drängt als man gedacht hat und dass die
Antworten eigentlich jetzt schon
vorliegen müssten vielleicht werden sie
ja dann in der Sommerpause gefunden hat
Energie vielen herzlichen Dank
der ukrainische Präsident selenski hatte
Vergeltung angekündigt für den
russischen Angriff auf Odessa und dort
die verklärungs Kathedrale und sogar gab
es dann heute wieder Attacken und aber
auch Gundula gegen Attacken
der Kreml hat allerdings bestritten das
russische Streitkräfte die Kathedrale
angegriffen hätten trotzdem attackierte
das ukrainische Militär erneut die Krim
und auch Moskau mit Drohnen in der
russischen Hauptstadt wurden mehrere
Gebäude beschädigt russland hat
seinerseits die Angriffe auf die Hafen
Infrastruktur an der Donau und auf
Odessa fortgesetzt dort wurden nach
ukrainischen Angaben sieben Menschen
verletzt so wie Silos und ein
Getreidelager zerstört
seit dem russischen Stopp des
getreideabkommens lässt Präsident Putin
täglich die ukrainischen Häfen angreifen
außerdem sagte er afrikanischen Staaten
zu sie mit russischem Getreide und
Düngemitteln zu beliefern zugleich
kündigte die Ukraine an auch ohne den
russischen Korridor im Schwarzen Meer
ihre Getreideexporte steigern zu wollen
über donauhelfen Straßen und per
Eisenbahn
vor dem Hintergrund der Spannungen mit
China hat Taiwan mit einem großen
Militärmanöver begonnen 5 Tage lang
sollen die Streitkräfte ihre
Kampfbereitschaft Proben für den Fall
einer Invasion auch die Abwehr von
Landungsschiffen wird geübt China sieht
das demokratische regierte Taiwan als
Teil der Volksrepublik und hat seit
Monaten den militärischen Druck erhöht
in Dutzenden Regionen Griechenlands
kämpfen Feuerwehrleute weiterhin gegen
zahlreiche schwere Waldbrände sowohl auf
dem Festland als auch auf beliebten
Ferieninseln auf Rhodos versuchen
Einsatzkräfte mit Löschflugzeugen und
Hubschraubern die Brände im Südosten der
Insel einzudämmen rund
9500 Menschen darunter viele Touristen
sind noch in Notunterkünften
untergebracht auf Korfu mussten in der
Nacht knapp 2500 Menschen vor einem
Waldbrand in Sicherheit gebracht werden
und auch in Algerien wüten fast 100
Waldbrände offenbar kamen dabei bislang
25 Menschen dort ums Leben es brennt an
der Mittelmeer Küste und in bergigen
Gebieten im Landesinnern
7.500 Feuerwehrleute und mehrere
Armeeeinheiten sind im Einsatz viele
Menschen mussten aus den gefehlten Orten
herausgebracht werden unter den Opfern
sind zehn Soldaten die die
Löschmannschaften unterstützt hatten
eine konservative Partei geht zusammen
mit einer
rechtspopulistischen wenn nicht gar
rechtsextremen Partei in Deutschland und
denkbar noch jedenfalls in Spanien wäre
es bei der Parlamentswahl gestern fast
so weit gekommen aber eben auch nur fast
denn der Wahlabend lief anders als die
Umfragen es im Vorfeld hatten er
Anlassen die konservative PP ist zwar
tatsächlich stärkste Kraft geworden hat
aber selbst im Zusammenschluss mit der
extremen Rechten VOX keine
Regierungsmehrheit der
sozialdemokratische Amtsinhaber konnte
also tatsächlich aufholen aber nicht
mehr überholen und jetzt dem Land das
gerade den Ratsvorsitz der Union inne
hat droht wohl eine lange hängerpartie
Thomas Weide
nach der wahlgeist hat ein Wort durch
die Straßen da dreht ein Wort dass man
in Spanien nach Wahlen schon öfter
gehört hat
es könnte zu einer Wiederholung der Wahl
kommen denn ich glaube nicht dass einer
nachgeben wird hoffen wir dass wir nicht
noch mal wählen müssen das wäre
furchtbar
eine Neuwahl wäre eine Katastrophe
Neuwahl dabei tat er noch in der Nacht
so als sei alles entschieden Alberto
Juniors Fero ließ sich von seiner
Volkspartei PP feiern nachdem die
zugelegt hatte und auf Platz 1 gelandet
war heute nachmittag erneuert er seinen
Anspruch Spaniens Ministerpräsident zu
werden
ich glaube es ist meine Pflicht und die
historische Verantwortung unserer Partei
die Regierung in Spanien zu bilden
noch Spanien doch welche Hoffnung
prallen auf einer republikanische Wand
hier im Parlament hat vier hoch keine
eigene Mehrheit obwohl er vor der Wahl
sogar eine Koalition mit den Rechtsaußen
von VOX nicht ausgeschlossen hatte eines
aber haben die Spanier gestern deutlich
gemacht
spanien ist ein komplexes Land aber
spanien will bestimmt keine Regierung in
der die extreme Rechte vertreten ist
möglicher Koalitionspartner verlor
Stimmen dabei hatte VOX sich schon als
mehrheitsmacher gesehen als das Ergebnis
dann kam
Petrus kann selbst als Wahl Verlierer
eine Amtseinführung blockieren und
schlimmer noch Petrus Sanchez könnte
sogar mit der Unterstützung von
Kommunisten separatistischen und
Terroristen wiedergewählt werden
tatsächlich wurde der bisherige
Regierungschef Petrus Sanchez heute von
den Sozialisten wie ein Gewinner
gefeiert Sanchez Taktik Angst zu schüren
für einem Rechtsrock verhinderte dass er
sein Amt verlor
Spanien und alle seine Bürger die zur
Wahl gegangen sind haben sich klar
ausgedrückt
der Block des Rückschritts der alle
Fortschritte die wir in den letzten vier
Jahren gemacht haben rückgängig machen
wollte ist
gescheiterto
Sanchez könnte nun sogar versuchen mit
Hilfe von katalanischen Separatisten
eine Mehrheit zustande zu bringen oder
wieder eine Minderheitsregierung das
Ring in der Parteien dürfte noch einige
Monate dauern und wenn es wie schon
mehrfach in der Vergangenheit nicht
klappt dann bleibt eben immer noch diese
unbeliebte Neuwahl
also die Gesellschaft polarisiert das
Ergebnis kompliziert eine neue Regierung
nicht in sich das sind keine gute
Nachrichten für die viertgrößte
Volkswirtschaft der EU und damit erstmal
zurück zur deutschen Politik und noch
mal zu dir Gundula
die Linkspartei hat ein Maßnahmenpaket
vorgestellt von dem sie sich mehr
soziale Gerechtigkeit verspricht der
Sozialstaat müsse armuts festgemacht
werden erklärte die Linke Parteichef
schiritt waren fordert unter anderem
einen Index Lohn also eine automatische
Anpassung an inflationsbedingte
Preissteigerungen wie es sie bereits
etwa in Belgien gibt außerdem fordert
DIE LINKE einen höheren Mindestlohn von
14 Euro sowie Obergrenzen für mieten
die Finanzmärkte schauen in dieser Woche
auf anstehende Entscheidungen der
US-Notenbank und der EZB die den
Leitzins bereits auf aktuell vier
Prozent angehoben hat während Kredite
immer teurer werden gehen viele Sparer
weiter leer aus Valerie Haller welche
bankkunden können denn mit Zinsen
rechnen und welche nicht einige müssen
ja noch komplett darauf verzichten bei
jeder fünften Bank gibt es nach wie vor
nullzins aufs Tagesgeldkonto ja und bei
Instituten die Zahlen gibt es erhebliche
Unterschiede vor allem zwischen Banken
die bundesweite Angebote machen und
jenen die regional arbeiten das
Vergleichsportal verivox hat die
Konditionen von rund 800 Banken
angeschaut und hier der Blick aufs
Tagesgeld bundesweite Institute Zahlen
im Schnitt 1,3% Zinsen
Genossenschaftsbanken und Sparkassen
0,36% Verbraucherschützer bemängeln
diese Unterschiede schon länger aber
auch die Bundesbank meint nun dass ich
Bank mit Zinsanpassungen teilweise mehr
Zeit lassen als in der Vergangenheit und
wie begründen die Geldhäuser ihr
Vorgehen also der ko-chef der
dz-bank-riese sagte kürzlich sie hätten
zum überwiegenden Teil die Kunden über
viele Jahre von Negativzinsen geschützt
jetzt brauche das System eine
Anpassungsphase bis es wieder im
Gleichgewicht sei laut Verivox
spekulieren regionale Banken stärker auf
die Treue ihrer Kunden und das erlaubt
es Ihnen zum Teil sehr niedrige Zinsen
zu zahlen wohin gegen deutschlandweite
Banken sich mehr dem Wettbewerb
ausgesetzt sehen und deswegen ihre
Angebote immer wieder nachbessern vielen
Dank für diese Informationen an Valerie
nach Frankfurt
bei der Frauenfußball WM in Australien
und Neuseeland ist die Gruppenphase in
vollem Gang mehr zum deutschen Erfolg
gleich hier zunächst die Ergebnisse der
anderen Spiele des Tages in der Gruppe G
siegte Italien gegen Argentinien mit 1:0
und in der Gruppe F gewann Brasilien
gegen Panama klar mit vier zu null
tja und dann das deutsche Team stark
geklappt Aufgabe souverän gelöst mund
abputzen weitermachen die 11 von
bundestrainerinnen Martina
forsthecklenburg hat zu Beginn der
Fußball-WM den WM Neuling Marokko mit
sechs zu null geschlagen die
4213 Formation hat also funktioniert
Alexandra Popp hat doppelt getroffen was
will man mehr alles aber bitte nicht
abheben so jedenfalls die
Bundestrainerin über das Spiel Miley
Scheidemann
wenn abheben dann nur zum Tore Köpfen
Alexandra Popp wie schon bei der EM im
letzten Jahr treffsicher in der Luft
erst wie im Lehrbuch dann akrobatisch
ich sehe einfach nur wo der Ball ist
sagen wir es mal so und ja am stärksten
bin ich mit dem Kopf egal in welcher
Höhe und in dem Fall war es dann auch so
das deutsche Team macht von Beginn an
Druck zwingt die Marokkanerin zu
Fehlpässen und dann ist es die
Innenverteidigerin die weit aufgerückt
ist Kati Hendricks findet die Kapitänen
1:0 nach 10 Minuten und auch in der 38
Minute ist Popp nicht zu stoppen setz
dich durch gegen zwei Marokkanerinnen
schon zur Halbzeit ist klar das was in
den Testspielen nicht funktioniert hat
klappt heute einwandfrei ich glaube das
wollte nur nicht auf uns sitzen lassen
in den vergangenen Spielen uns
vorgeworfen wurde wurde dass wir unsere
Chance nicht nutzen ich glaube
effektiver geht's kaum als heute nur 21
Sekunden nach wieder Anpfiff dieses
Szene Brand liegt ab auf immer Gold
Latten Kreuz und wenn 30 nicht einigen
können dann kommt Clara Bühl zum 3:0
belohnt sich für ein starkes Spiel die
Marokkanerin mittlerweile überfordert
als
er hat stolpert den Ball ins eigene Tor
und auch reduani kann den Druck der
deutschen Mannschaft nicht standhalten
5:0 nach 78 Minuten
wir sind in der letzten Spielminute
mittlerweile fünf neue deutsche
Spielerinnen auf dem Feld und die
harmonieren gut Freigang auf Latein und
dann steht Schiller da wo eine Stürmerin
stehen sollte 6:0 der entstand so hoch
hat bisher bei dieser WM noch kein Team
geworden
wir heben nicht ab wir haben den ersten
Sieg erreicht das wollten wir wir haben
uns ein bisschen was verschafft auch mit
vielen Toren es könnte auch wichtig sein
von daher ja sind wir zufrieden heute
nicht mehr und ich weniger der erste
Schritt ist gemacht jetzt hat das Team 5
Tage Zeit um sich auf den wohl stärksten
Gruppengegner vorzubereiten
also das nächste Spiel dann am Sonntag
um 11:30 Uhr gegen Kolumbien und für
heute Abend empfehlen wir ihn noch unser
heute journal Update mit Nazan gökte mir
direkt nach dem montagskino um 23:45 Uhr
und das war es von uns machen sie es gut
wo auch immer sie sind bis morgen
tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend das wird eine zum Teil
regnerische gewittrige und auch kühle
sommerwetterwoche das sehen sie ja auch
in dem blauen Pfeil und wenn sie ganz
genau hinschauen dann sehen Sie hier
weiße Punkte in den Alpen denn am
Mittwoch kann es bis auf 2000 Meter
runter in den Alpen schneiden heute
Nacht ziehen die Gewitter hier auswärts
ab aus den Alpen entwickelt sich dann
immer neue Gewitter und die Temperaturen
sinken auf Werte zwischen 16 Grad zum
Beispiel hier östlich von München und 10
Grad im Sauerland die Höchsttemperaturen
morgen liegen zwischen 16 Grad in der
Eifel oder im Hunsrück und maximal 23
Grad in Berlin-Brandenburg und im
östlichen Sachsen auch morgen fällt
häufig Regen in der Südhälfte zum Teil
ist der auch mit Gewittern durchsetzt
Regenschauer gibt's auch an der Nordsee
Freund hier sieht's aus und die sind
Dreieck Hannover Schwerin Berlin da
sehen sie häufiger mal die Sonne bei
einem Wind aus westlichen bis
nordwestlichen Richtung am Mittwoch
erinnert sich an diesem Wetter wenig der
Donnerstag wird in Süddeutschland
sonniger und der Freitag dann von Westen
deutlich